donald trump has been the central figure
in a culture war in america
over whether or not to wear a face mask
in the pandemic
for that reason this was a significant
moment
for the first time ever the president
seen wearing a face mask
in public in accordance with his own
government's guidance
on a visit to a military hospital in
washington
on closer inspection his mask came
complete with a presidential seal
on his way he'd explained why the change
of approach
i think when you're in a hospital
especially in that particular setting
where you're talking to a lot of
soldiers and people that in some cases
just got off the operating tables
i think it's a great thing to wear a
mask i've never been against masks
but i do believe they have a time and a
place
it was only three months ago he
announced that government guidance
and then said he'd ignore it it's
voluntary you don't have to do it
they suggest it for a period of time
but uh this is voluntary
i don't think i'm going to be doing it
the man who wants to take his job has
been conspicuous in his adherence to the
guidance
and joe biden's campaign again
criticized the president
in a statement they said rather than
taking responsibility and leading
he wasted four months that americans
have been making sacrifices
by stoking divisions and actively
discouraging people from taking a very
basic step
to protect each other all the while the
number of new cases in the us continues
to break records
as states like florida are pushing ahead
with their reopening
disney world in orlando the most popular
theme park in the world
has started accepting visitors again
florida has recorded 500 deaths
in the last week alone hospitals are
approaching capacity
in a number of states and experts warn
the numbers will only rise
it's an uncomfortable position for a
president accused of mismanaging the
crisis
and keen to declare america on the road
to recovery
and whose chances of a second term
probably depend on it
greg milam sky news los angeles